BUT FIRST, CONSERVATIVES STRIKE
BACK AT THE NRA BOYCOTT.
THAT'S THE FOCUS OF TONIGHT'S
ANGLE.
AFTER THAT MASSACRE AT THAT
PARKLAND, FLORIDA HIGH SCHOOL,
STUDENTS TURNED ACTIVISTS TURNED
THEIR SIGHTS ON THE NRA.
>> I'M GLAD THAT COMPANIES,
WHICH ARE WHAT WILL STOP THE NRA
FROM DOING WHAT THEY'RE DOING
AND BASICALLY KILLING KIDS, THE
COMPANIES ARE GOING TO BE THE
ONES THAT ARE GOING TO STOP
THIS.
AND I'M CALLING OUT EVERY SINGLE
COMPANY RIGHT NOW WHO IS NOT IN
FAVOR OF CONDUCTING THEIR TIES
WITH THE NRA.
THE NRA HAS SHOWN THEMSELVES TO
BE TOXIC, VILE, AND TO NOT
SUPPORT THE RIGHT TO LIVE, WHICH
IS IN THE PREAMBLE OF THE
CONSTITUTION.
>> I WOULD SAY PLANNED
PARENTHOOD HASN'T SUPPORTED THE
RIGHT TO LIVE.
THE NRA HAS BEEN IN BUSINESS
SINCE 1871 AND DOES MORE TO
PROMOTE RESPONSIBLE GUN
OWNERSHIP AND GUN SAFETY THAN
ANY OTHER ORGANIZATION IN THE
COUNTRY.
THE FACT IS NIKOLAS CRUZ SHOULD
NEVER HAD GOTTEN HIS GUN BECAUSE
HE WAS A MENTAL CASE.
HE WAS ENGAGED IN VIOLENCE AT
SCHOOL AND ON THE INTERNET.
THE GUN CONTROL GANG HAS
MISDIAGNOSED THIS PROBLEM.
WE NEED TO KNOW THE REAL CAUSE
OF THE FLORIDA SHOOTING TO HELP
PREVENT THIS IN THE FUTURE.
WHY AREN'T WE LOOKING AT THE
EFFECTS OF THEMSELF LIKE THE
PROMISE PROGRAM AT THE SCHOOL?
THAT INCENTIVIZED KEEPING THE
SHOOTER'S DISTURBING AND
CRIMINAL ACTIONS FROM THE POLICE
AND ALLOWED CRUZ TO KEEP A CLEAN
RECORD.
AND SO WHEN WE WENT TO BUY GUNS,
SHE WASN'T STOPPED.
AND WHAT HAPPENED HIS TUMULT
AND WHAT HAPPENED HIS TUMULTOU
AND WHAT HAPPENED HIS TUMULTOUS
FAMILY LIFE?
BUT INSTEAD LIBERAL ACTIVISTS
IGNORE THOSE AND OTHER POLITICAL
FACTORS AND SCAPEGOATING THEIR
FAVORITE BOOGIE MAN AND
POLITICAL ENEMY, THE NRA.
THROUGH SOCIAL MEDIA PRESSURE,
THEY WERE ABLE TO GET MORE THAN
A DOZEN COMPANIES, HERTZ,
METLIFE, BEST WESTERN,
BUT NOW, THE GEORGIA STATE
LEGISLATURE, WHICH GRANTED
MILLIONS IN TAX BREAKS TO DELTA
AIRLINES DECIDED IT HAD HAD JUST
ABOUT ENOUGH.
THE LAWMAKERS IN GEORGIA VOTED
TO STRIP DELTA, WHICH IS
HEADQUARTERED IN ATLANTA, ALL OF
OF ITS HEAVY JET FUEL TAX
EXEMPTIONS.
THAT COSTS A LOT.
CORPORATIONS CANNOT ATTACK
CONSERVATIVES AND EXPECT US NOT
TO FIGHT BACK.
WELL, TODAY DELTA'S CEO ISSUES A
MEMO TO EMPLOYEES THAT THEY WERE
IN A PROCESS TO END DISCOUNTS TO
A GROUP OF ANY POLITICALLY
DEVISIVE NATURE.
BUT WHAT ABOUT VALUING AND
PROTECTING YOUR CUSTOMERS?
WHY ALIENATE THEM?
YOU KNOW WHAT I WAS THINKING
ABOUT TODAY AS I WAS GETTING
READY FOR THE SHOW?
REMEMBER HOW THIS LINE FROM
OBAMA WENT OVER IN MIDDLE
AMERICA?
>> THE JOBS HAVE BEEN GONE NOW
FOR 25 YEARS AND NOTHING'S
REPLACED THEM.
AND THEY'RE GONE THROUGH THE
CLINTON ADMINISTRATION AND BUSH
ADMINISTRATION.
AND EACH ADMINISTRATION HAS SAID
THAT SOMEHOW THESE ARE GOING TO
REGENERATE.
AND THEY HAVE NOT.
SO IT'S NOT SURPRISING.
>>OH, I'M JUST A BITTER
CLINGER.
I'LL NEVER GET OVER THAT LINE.
BUT IT WAS SO CONDESCENDING, SO
INSULTING, AND IT WAS WRONG
THEN, AND WHAT THESE
CORPORATIONS ARE DOING TO THE
NRA IS WRONG NOW.
BECAUSE OF THE CORPORATE
COWARDICE OF THESE COMPANIES,
PEOPLE WHO AREN'T NRA MEMBERS
ARE ACTUALLY CONSIDERING
JOINING.
>> I'M NOT AN NRA MEMBER, BUT
I'M THINKING ABOUT.
I THINK THE PUBLICITY THEY'VE
GOTTEN HAS ALLOWED PEOPLE TO
FIGURE OUT WHOSE SIDE WE WANT TO
BE ON THE SIDE OF.
>> I'M DEFINITELY LIBERAL ABOUT
JUST ABOUT EVERYTHING EXCEPT FOR
THIS.
I THINK IF WE STOP KIND OF DEMON
I THINK IF WE STOP KIND OF DEM N
DEMONIZE
DEMONIZ
DEMO
DEMONIZING GUN OWNERS, WE MIGHT
BE ABLE TO COME UP WITH